[Applaudissements]
des chants de la sauge brûlé un hommage
spontané aux 215 enfants enlevés de leur
famille pour être placé au pensionnat de
kamloops abidjan 6 s'est rendu sur place
pour que les esprits de ses enfants
oubliés puisque enfin rentrer à la
maison
ses parents ont vécu aussi dans un
pensionnat pour cette femme à la fois
mère et grand mère
la douleur est vive
même si à kamloops l'histoire du
pensionnat et connu l'ampleur de
l'horreur dépasse l'entendement devant
le bâtiment le monument commémoratif aux
élèves autochtones est devenu un lieu de
recueillement autochtone et blanche se
succèdent pour y déposer des fleurs ou
écrire un mot à la mémoire des disparus
[Musique]
pour la communauté de tekken loupe
déchet technique
beaucoup de questions demeurent sans
réponse mais la première nation est
déterminé à faire toute la lumière sur
ces disparitions
encore sous le choc et la douleur la
communauté veut tout faire pour guérir
les cérémonies rituelles ce compte
entamer sans tarder pour que la vie
puisse reprendre ses droits
entre temps les recherches ne font que
commencer un rapport plus détaillé sur
la découverte des 215 dépouille sera
publié dans les prochaines semaines ici
mathieu gaye et radio canada
kamloops